good morning as for Gwyneth Paltrow's
Court battle today kicked off week two
of her ski crash trial
gwenth took her seat and a Time smirked
while the plaintiff 76 year old Terry
Sanderson took the stand I heard a blood
curdling scream
just I can't do it
and then
Gwyneth of course claimed she was the
one hit during her testimony and her
time on the stand has become one big
meme are you good friends with Taylor
Swift no one person compared this
exchange to an SNL skit I'm just under 5
10. okay I am so jealous I think I'm
shrinking though you and me both I have
to wear four inch heels just to make it
to five five so they're very nice oh
thank you another call to quote the very
widest most privileged lawsuit I've ever
seen after the incident you got a
massage I still felt very shaky I
decided to go in early and get a massage
my yoga instructor decided I don't like
you anymore well I lost half a day of
skiing
across the pond Prince Harry shocked
everyone with this surprise appearance
in London's high court for a preliminary
hearing in his lawsuit against the
publisher of the Daily Mail
the Duke of Sussex appeared relaxed
despite nearly colliding with a
cameraman after photographers swarmed to
get the shot sorry hello how are you
Elton John also a plaintiff in the
lawsuit arrived a few hours later both
allege the publisher engaged in years of
criminal activity including phone
tapping and other privacy breaches which
the defendants deny by this point
courtesy of the Daily Mail of the world
knew exact our exact location we had to
take legal action it's believed Harry is
staying at Frogmore Cottage just 26 days
after receiving a fiction notice from
King Charles so could Harry visit his
family while in London well not his
father or Prince William ET has learned
both are out of town
[Music]